reading sped up footage used to zoom
audience over la skyline coming disaster
as punishment for human solutions in
case the skyline flyover didn't do it
it's followed by a gratuitous montage of
le landmarks John Corbett isn't being a
charming small-town radio DJ and/or
breaking up with Sarah Jessica Parker in
this scene Mike makes his dog eat eggs
next to a piping hot skillet translation
Rolex outbid tag for the product
placement gig not me
I love earthquakes especially at
hospitals volcano caused by an
earthquake nerd glasses are nerdy right
after the earthquake at 914 a.m. the
police get a call about a 914 in
progress coincidence or aliens nicorette
gum as character development are they
holding this press conference in a
gymnasium without asking these guys to
stop shooting for a few minutes the
Metro red line workers computer has
software built-in to track and score
their illegal side bets on the epicenter
of earthquakes we interrupt this
disaster movie to bring you a
supervillain origin story
the volcanic gas burned only one side of
this guy's face so that it would be
dramatic for the audience later also
Tommy Lee Jones let someone else play
two-face in this scene dormant volcano
directly underneath Los Angeles somehow
went unnoticed for years by every single
scientist geologists and various nerd in
the entire world that metal door kept
rat killing molten heat at bay I can't
believe he owns Rummikub also how many
globes do you need in this house unibrow
is Uni uses the vague term geologic
events so that Mike can ask what the
hell that is and we can get a lesson on
plate tectonics and magma are you
serious scientists definition of
knowledge is different from the
dictionary surely this movie definitely
needed a romantic subplot between the 28
year-old Anne Heche and the 51 year-old
Tommy Lee Jones also right after Amy
makes a remark about not being taken
seriously because they're women they
launch right into this she needs a man
portion of the movie we'll be right back
after this commercial break where is the
volcano erupts under Los Angeles chapter
of this book
sure gather samples while crouching down
directly over the fissure this is gonna
get a lot worse before it gets better
the gas coming from this fissure
conveniently decides not to ship into
and Bank the entire tunnel so that Mamie
can survive this unholy fissure of death
just killed my partner let's look down
into it so wait a minute do you mean
that while all this is going on with the
manhole covers blowing their lids and
volcanic rocks flying all over the place
but the tunnel amy was in managed to be
calm during all that how did the
conductor survive all those rocks
smashing directly into him a few minutes
ago all the looters have to run in the
same direction apparently oh no the dog
well the little dog make it to safety if
this one dog makes it out then that will
make up for the thousands that didn't
off-screen
what the flick lady she would love
seeing people die and suffer and burn
there's no way they could hear her
yelling and even if they could are they
gonna listen to some random lady
shouting in the street what is this plan
supposed to do again they're gonna lay a
bus in front of the lava and then what
unfortunately we don't ever find out
what this likely stupid plan is since
Amy interrupts Mike mid-sentence because
he doesn't know what to call the lava
were they standing right there while the
cops on the other side fired their guns
in this direction you mean including any
buses you might decide to put in front
of it
oh come on also the other trees are
still standing even though they've been
sitting in lava far longer the bus isn't
doing jack oh so the lava is alive and
sentient oh it's just like crash only
with more volcanoes this guy can't
believe that the firefighter doesn't
know what street he's talking about even
though all of Los Angeles appears to be
burning right now what did you say boss
I could understand you while you were
running and shouting and while everyone
else was running and you know over all
the general commotion lava melts the
biggest human antagonist of the movie
and we're supposed to feel bad about it
it takes 20 seconds for lava to melt a
man but it takes several hours for it to
knock down these trees unless one of
them wants to inconveniently trap people
next to a bus not one single person has
a radio in all this mess how do you
coordinator job like this by yelling
when there's all this hustle and bustle
of the concrete dividers really form an
airtight seal am I the only one worried
about lava leaks here racist cop
immediately gets out of the way when a
black guy he arrested yells something at
him I'm so glad this racist subplot
turned into something positive
also this is the fastest racial
reconciliation since that very special
Fresh Prince episode see you like this
gap here in the concrete is that really
gonna stop lava or any liquid at all
from getting through there
normally I just ding dialogue this bad
and move on but this is so exceptionally
terrible that I think I've been have to
go the extra step I'm also saying what
the fuck is wrong with you Hollywood is
this guy really doing a live remote
three feet in front of the lava pretty
much her jubilation those houses should
be completely gone by now and wasn't
that Street getting covered in lava too
also if that neighborhood on a side
street was getting covered in lava how
did stopping the lava flow on Wilshire
prevent the lava from going further into
that neighborhood we stopped building
under the Bellevue Center or less gonna
go movie attempts to make the huge
volcano eruption more dramatic by
putting the protagonist daughter right
in the crossfire I know that I said them
all over there along with my daughter
[Music]
you don't have time for this man I'm
with you it's total bullshit so you
wanted to blow up the street not kind of
lazy no way babe a whole lot more than
60 seconds went by since you said 20
minutes were left sure I'm glad this
movie spent time fleshing out this
subplot or else I might not have given a
damn oh wait I still don't I also now
mike has a radio and quite conveniently
for the movie it doesn't work building
collapses in slow motion in the
background while everyone else in the
foreground moves at normal speed oh you
didn't see that Mike out runs a
collapsing building and somehow tackles
the kids far enough out of the way to
safety unlikely
how neat that is to be able to survive a
building falling on you and have easily
removed rubble fall in a pile near you
and not on you
[Music]
thanks to the volcano no one was racist
in Los Angeles ever again thank God they
drove max all the way out here so he
could be with the family at the end of
the movie also did they make a special
trip to get the dog before they came
here look for oh that phone is done more
reading also suspenseful word crawl
takes forever but tells us everything we
need to know as soon as the letter A
shows up
[Music]
got a ribbon here can you hear us can
you make a knocking sound again sound
like a Zola Budd it was it was two
knocks both thump that's you banging
thank you you just want to be sure that
it's really you
my kids that you've sent along the line
they would like to speak with you target
search of every gas station residents
what is it hi
[Music]
[Laughter]